so Donald Trump's tax returns uh confirm  every single one of our suspicions for  example he's not as wealthy it appears  as he has claimed to be he does mess  around with the values of assets when  it's convenient either saying that  they're hired to get a loan or to say  that they're lower to avoid property  taxes he does have all sorts of strange  creditors he pays very little in taxes  all of it is true but it's important to  remember that Trump's not the only rich  person that is doing a lot of the things  that Trump is doing most of them are  doing it and so much of this as much as  it is about Trump is about the system  that allows people in positions of  extreme wealth to take advantage of that  very system in order to pay little or no  taxes yes Trump is a big part of it but  it's much bigger than Trump